I am so envious of you not just because
you get to kick the out of people
on television which has been my dream
all my life and then this happened I
think you have one of the best voices
I've heard in a long time I have always
hated my voice you have an incredibly
great deep voice I mean it's okay you
know I hate I'm glad we or through the
era of the voice recorder where you call
in and the answering machine I hated
hearing that playback but here it's
pretty good you know it changed when I
was like 10 years old or something your
voice changed when you were 10
about 10 yeah yeah I was in a playground
yeah your voice is in jail yeah I think
mine changed during the second term of
Obama's presidency before that I was
like welcome to the show and then it all
changed so really you were that young
yeah about about 10 I was walking around
the playground you know the voice it's
kind of high and then it was like good
and then it went back up again it was
kind of I thought it was an accident and
I was talking again and they were very
and it went like that again and then all
my friends were like that's weird
and so it was weird it wasn't like a
cool thing was just weird right and then
it just dropped in one day and all of a
sudden I was like just talking like this
the rest of my life yeah
when did you realize like okay this will
be an asset for me in my life when did
you start to get maybe special attention
or no I think I was I think I was on to
something I knew I was on to something
when my art teacher started giving me
extra time in class and she was trying
to show me how to draw and she would
lean over on me and I'd be sitting here
and then she would put her you know her
you know her whatever you call those
things she put him out of my head here
and her breasts that were they are
breasts I didn't know if you meant that
or like her spectacles
I'm going for clarity arrogant funbags
but I was like is that is that kosher
funbags you know so she would press them
against my head and she would show me
how to draw things and I was just the
whole time I never learned anything
because I was so so distracted and I
just look up and I just remember
pressing him down on my head and I
remember her asking me a lot of
questions because she said oh you have a
really deep voice is like as your dad
have a deep voice and I was like what
what does she want know about my dad boy
I could I couldn't figure it out right
yeah so ten years later I was like oh
that's what she was asking me about yeah
I had I had a chance with her and I was
[Laughter]
you